it's the fourth annual Berlin Music Week
concerts and parties draw tens of
thousands of music lovers to the German
capital meanwhile music business
professionals are here to discuss the
future of the industry singer/songwriter
davila metla is on a musical boat tour
presented by pop export and the German
government's music initiative a final
sound check before the performance
the audience on board include music
journalists and concert promoters from
around the world along with two other
up-and-coming bands Bolivian born beetle
amantha wants to catch the ear of those
in the business especially expecting a
lot from tonight because they can't
leave the boat since it has em I'm sure
there are a lot of music experts and
people who know quite a lot about music
which is a difficult audience it's a
challenge we're happy to take on but
david has to wait his turn first up the
Hamburg indie band peel and the pop trio
Ballet School from Berlin they are all
being supported by the music initiative
a funding agency set up by the German
government to promote new talent the
boat tour passes by Austin where many of
the major record labels have their
offices a few meters farther away is the
heart of Berlin music week the old post
bunnell during the day bands agents and
music managers from around the world
gather here Berlin is a magnet for
creative types and not just because the
cost of living is cheap
you go over something I think what
really works in Berlin is this
networking people love to talk about
networking which is very very important
for artists and I think here you can get
into certain circles very quickly you
can get in quickly in the smaller labels
at the smaller publishing houses large
Christine Kunak works for a German
record label she's taking part today in
a workshop called most wanted music
American talent scouts are on the
lookout for new music for film and
television a big chance for her roles do
this thing you have to select the right
music music supervisors are flooded with
music and a lot of it comes down to luck
she was invited by nay rip America's
national association of record industry
professionals Christine is presenting
songs by two of her artists feedback is
immediate I like the exotic quality of
it and i also like the fact that it's
not a play civil in sense of geography
but it's Dina doesn't know if the
professionals will use her music but she
says the workshop was worth it I get to
know the supervisor and you see how
things work the tips forgot from tasin
from Michael were really helpful at
night this former post office turns into
a meeting place for visitors and concert
goers it's just one of many party
locations in the German capital
back to the boat or daddy Dimitra can
finally get his chance the
singer-songwriter has found more than
just a musical home in Berlin ines Akkad
is one thing I totally love about Berlin
is that you might not become a real
Berliner right away but at least you can
feel like one then that's really nice
it's a city that really welcomes you
everyone here is on the way toward
realizing their own dreams
davila maitre has come one step closer
to his dream of international success at
the Berlin music week his songs even won
over the professionals